[Musique]
bienvenue sur les plateaux date a dit
d'interdire 2020 ils ont été une année
de rapprochement de mars avec la terre
trois missions ont donc été lancée vers
la planète rouge
une de chine le 23 juillet une autre des
émirats arabes unis est parti du japon
le 20 juillet le lancement du rover
persévérance de la nasa a eu lieu lui
aussi cet été ils amarrent siradan une
cinquantaine de jours il va chercher des
preuves que des bactéries vivait sur
mars il y a trois milliards d'années
je reçois donc aujourd'hui sylvia
extrême docteur en astrophysique
spécialisé en physique stellaire vous
publié chez favre avec le graphiste
ravier non bella qui est assis à côté de
vous un livre tout à fait passionnant
intitulé nous ne vivrons pas sur mars
ni ailleurs c'est préfacé par le prix
nobel de physique
le michel mayor dans lequel un livre
dans lequel vous étudiez tout ce que
nécessite un vol habité pour mars et ce
n'est pas aussi simple que voudrait nous
le faire croire
elon musk mais commençons d'abord par ce
qui caractérise notre époque comme c'est
la tradition dans cette émission
vas-y l'image que vous avez choisi vous
allez devoir nous expliquer ce que l'on
y voit alors on voit une magnifique
image de saturne qui a été prise par la
sonde cassini en 2013 en juillet 2013 et
la particularité c'est qu'en fait on
voit saturne depuis son autre l'autre
côté que ce que nous on peut voir depuis
la terre et saturn éclipse de soleil
donc déjà ça fait une photo absolument
splendide mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait on y voit
la terre alors on va voir apparaître la
terre et alors il faut comprendre que la
terre c'est le tout petit point bhl
minuscule au bout de la flèche
exactement et donc là on se rend compte
à quel point notre petite planète est
minuscule on a souvent l'impression que
c'est une espèce de réserve immense pour
notre croissance infinie mais ça n'est
pas le cas c'est un tout petit caillou
dans un immense espace vide
et là on se rend compte que même déjà
simplement depuis saturne au fait qui
est pourtant là trois planètes plus loin
c'est vraiment pas très loin et bien la
terre est minuscule et et vénus et c'est
tout petit os x est un minuscule point
au bout de la flèche et mars c'est aussi
un minuscule point exactement
oui qui sont un peu
bhl je pense à l'écran mais ça prouve
bien ce que nous apprend la géographie
planétaire à quel point les planètes
telluriques sont minuscules même vu
depuis sa tombe
alors commençons par ce que révèle votre
livre moi ça m'a absolument passionné je
suis un petit garçon des années 60
donc j'ai vu la conquête spatiale j'ai
vu l'homme a marché sur la lune et mars
évidemment ça continue de me faire rêver
comme la plupart des gens alors déjà
commençons par la distance entre la
terre et mars
il faut bien comprendre que la lune
c'est à 384 1400 km de la terre et ça ne
bouge pas 1
c'est toujours à cette distance là en
revanche avec marc c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué au moment où marcelo s'est le
plus rapproché de la terre ça n'était
pas arrivé depuis soixante mille ans
c'était en 2003 on était à 55 millions
de kilomètres mais ça peut aller jusqu'à
420 millions de kilomètres c'est à dire
mille fois moins 1000 fois plus loin que
la lune
vous avez d'ailleurs des images dans
votre livre qu'on va voir
vous allez pouvoir qu'augmenter comment
calcule-t-on la distance entre la terre
et mars
on a effectivement ça change tout le
temps en fait puisque les deux planètes
tournent autour du soleil
chacune a sa vitesse la thèse est plus
proche du soleil donc elle tourne plus
vite elle tourne en mon nom et ma c'est
plus lointaines donc elle tourne un peu
plus de deux ans et en fait pour que les
deux planètes se retrouvent dans la même
configuration il faut attendre 26 mois
en fait et c'est seulement à ce moment
là qu'on retrouve mars proche de la
terre tout le reste du temps on s'en est
éloignée de plus en plus et d'ailleurs
on ne voit mars dans le ciel que tous
les deux ans en fait il ya une année où
on ne verra jamais la nuit dans le ciel
donc cette année on était assez proche
de mars c'est pour ça qu'on alors c'est
tellement mission absolument mais comme
vous l'avez dit donc en 2003 on a été à
55 milles kilomètres ce qui est très
rare
cette année quand on était au plus fort
je mettais à 70 millions donc vous voyez
qu'il ya une grande différence selon
selon les années et fethi ben alors ce
qu'il faut comprendre aussi que c'est
que quand on est allé sur la lune
c'était un voyage en ligne droite si on
veut aller sur mars
c'est un voyage en courbe oui alors même
pour aller sur la lune s'était
légèrement en courbe quand même au 6 mai
mais oui dans l'espace le soleil est une
masse très importante dans le système
solaire et donc c'est impossible d'aller
en ligne droite de la terre à mars parce
que le soleil va courber les
trajectoires de toute façon donc on est
obligé en fait de lancer nos sont sur
une sur une trajectoire courbe qu'on
appelle une orbite de transfert et du
coup c'est très très long en fait on va
pas du tout du plus court directement
d'une planète à l'autre
au moment où elles sont au plus proche
on est obligé de commencer un voyage et
avant que mars nous est dépassé et de
voyager en courbe
pendant six mois à peu près six à sept
mois oui il ya constamment des
corrections de trajectoire en fait
surtout au démarrage et à l'arrivée pas
spécialement pendant le vol
qu'est ce que ça change le fait qu'ils
aient des corrections de trajectoire et
chaque fois qu'on corrige la trajectoire
on prend un risque ou pas bah si on rate
la correction oui on prend les traits ou
si on en fait continue tout droit dans
l'espace en fait c'est ce qui arrive est
typiquement à la tesla elon musk il a
lancé sa tesla pour voilà pour faire un
peu de pub est soi-disant il l'a lancée
vers mars mais évidemment il n'y avait
pas de trajet de corrections de
trajectoire prévue pour cette voiture
est en fait l air entre le soleil la
terre et mars sur une orbite tout à fait
incontrôlés ce qui se ressent ça serait
dommage
c'est alors jusqu'à présent on a posé
des objets sur mars mais vous dites que
c'est chaud des objets de moins d'une
tonne
les rovers les caméras etc etc et non
seulement il était relativement léger en
bus ils devaient parvenir là si on veut
aller sur mars nous les humains il va
falloir peser à un appareil beaucoup
plus lourd et puis il va falloir qui
redécolle et qu'il revienne
absolument c'est en fait le gros écueil
technologique je dirais pour l'instant
c'est l'atterrissage s'est pas fait
encore on n'a encore jamais fait quelque
chose d'aussi lourds qu'une fusée
habiter où aucune fusée qui contiendrait
du cargo pour pour construire des
habitats avant l'arrivée des humains il
faut il faut bien imaginer qu'on va pas
envoyer les mots nomme directement les
poser comme ça sur un vol d'essai on va
d'abord essayer de poser des choses plus
lourdes et donc le ce qui est prévu
c'est d'envoyer des carbo avant mais on
sait pas faire encore donc on va
découvrir un petit peu les choses
mars est un grand cimetière de sondes
qui parce que beaucoup se sont écrasés
et ont raté leur atterrissage et il n'y
a pas de raison qu avec des fusées plus
lourde ce soit on est un meilleur bilan
dont on va commencer par an d'écraser un
certain nombre je pense et puis on va
apprendre de nos erreurs et puis sont
peut-être un jour arriver à poser des
humains mais mais il va déjà falloir
apprendre à poser du lourd sur la
surface
vous dites encore atterrissage vous
dites pas à marcher sage 1 6 1 oui il va
falloir s'habituer
ce sera une amarre si sage et se roder
martiaux note
il faut surtout se rendre compte que ce
seront pas à première vue des appareils
d'environ 30 tonnes ce qui est
actuellement envisagée par la nasa
devant atterrir sur une planète qui à
0,6 pour cent l'atmosphère terrestre
donc compter sur le freinage
atmosphérique
c'est pas possible donc vraiment c'est
un c'est une question qui actuellement
n'est pas vraiment résolu quoi alors la
durée du voyage parce que c'est ça qui
est qui qui vu le plus important et le
musk a parlé de voyage qui pourrait
prendre 80 jours et qui emmènerait 100 à
200 personnes
vous dites c'est absolument inimaginable
en l'état actuel de nos connaissances en
fait ça sous-entend qu'il faut remplir
les
de fioul la fusée après son décollage on
peut pas faire décoller une fusée et
qu'elle est encore assez de fioul pour
faire suffisamment de corrections de
trajectoire pour faire un voyage aussi
rapide
donc ça veut dire il va y avoir scié
ensuite et pouvoir être capable alors
pour le redécollage on suppose qu'on va
fabriquer les halles gaulle sur place
c'est la seule façon en fait de re
décoller mais pour pour le voyage pour
que le voyage soit aussi court il faut
des corrections de trajectoire assez
vigoureuse et et nombreuses et donc il
s'agit de ravitailler la fusée en vol
c'est à dire la faire décoller la garder
en orbite terrestre la ravitailler et
l'envoyer sur mars
et ça alors bien sûr c'est un oui on
connaît l'idée et si vous voulez mais on
admet aimer personne n'a jamais fait ça
la technologie voilà il faut il faut
l'inventer en fait encore et rien ne dit
que ce soit faisable
enfin voilà surtout que pour arriver à
faire un voyage en 80 jours il faut
doubler la vitesse que qu'on donne
actuellement au centre qui vont sur mars
ce qui était encore une fois très
compliqué même pour descendre mais alors
pour une fusée de type de starship à
l'oreille pour pour avoir une idée
encore une fois de la distance
parce que les américains disent aussi
manque pourrait peut-être faire partir
de la fusée de la lune
ça nous ferait déjà gagné un peu de un
peu de distance mais mais vous le dites
dans votre livre
si la terre est une orange à peu près de
cette taille là il faut se dire que la
station spatiale internationale et à 2
mm 2 les corses de l'oranje la lune ll
est apte de m déjà c'est beaucoup de
maîtres c'est là-bas et mars ce serait
entre eux 300 mètres et 2 km par rapport
à la roche
donc on voit que c'est pas du tout les
mêmes c'est pas les mêmes donc si on
part de la lune ça nous fait gagner un
peu mais pas beaucoup
c'est pas tellement pour gagner de la
distance en fait de partir de la lune
c'est plus pour gagner du poids pouvoir
faire décoller quelque chose de plus
lourd pouvoir faire décoller une fusée
avec des réservoirs plus grand et donc
plus de réserves de fioul pour faire ces
corrections de trajectoire je pense que
ce n'est pas tellement la distance qui
nous intéresse c'est vraiment qu'on
puisse comme la gravitation de la lune
est très légère est très faible
ça permet de faire décoller plus
facilement une fusée plus lourde c'est
surtout ça le
l'option alors quand on a envoyé des
objets des sondes sur mars
on sait ça a pris environ au minimum 2
128 jours
donc vous vous avez fait vos calculs sur
un voyage de six à sept mois entre entre
180 et 210 jours voire plus
vous imaginez donc un voyage sur mars
dont on revient parce qu'il y en a qui
imagine qu on reste là où pour coloniser
c'est un autre problème vous y
répondrait également mai mais en
attendant imaginons qu'on revient vous
dites que ça fera un voyage d'au moins 3
ans en fait parce qu'il va falloir
trouver aussi une fenêtre de retour
exactement du fait du mouvement des deux
planètes on peut pas partir de la terre
pour aller sur mars n'importe quand mais
on peut pas non plus partir de mars pour
revenir sur terre n'importe quand et si
on parle de toute façon si on part à des
moments différents
on va devoir enfin la longueur du trajet
de voyage va compenser le gain en étant
parti plus vite donc ça remonte gagne
rien en fait en gros il faut vraiment
compter trois ans pour une mission aller
retour alors trois ans à la banque sur
la station spatiale internationale la
consommation de nourriture c'est 1 kg
par personne et par jour et 11 litres
d'eau même si l'eau est recyclée un lot
lui rinne tout est recyclé sur la
station spatiale internationale
vous imaginez qu'il faudra être au moins
quatre personnes pour aller sur mars
donc ça fait 4 4 tonnes de nourriture et
3,4 tonnes d'eau sachant qu évidemment
on ne peut pas être ravitaillée là bas
un alors pour l'eau on a des espoirs
d'arriver en extraire de soi du sol
martien qui contient de la glace soit
deux calottes polaires soit de fond de
fond de cratères où il ya peut-être de
la glace c'est un désespoir cd c'est
d'arriver à extraire sa à extraire un
peu d'eau à pouvoir utiliser l'eau
locale en fait
la nourriture ça il faut vraiment tout
emporté un autre aspect c'est l'oxygène
des astronautes ça respire contrairement
aux sondes ça consomme pas seulement de
la nourriture ça consomme aussi de
l'oxygène là aussi l'idée c'est
d'arriver à extraire l'oxygène de
l'atmosphère martienne du co2 martien en
fait et la sonde persévérance va
justement effectué des tests ce même
oxygène à noter non seulement il permet
aux astronautes de respirer mais il
pourrait être utilisé comme fuel de
retour dans la dans la capsule
donc pour pour rose ça permettrait en
fait de fabriquer les rigoles de retour
grâce à cet oxygène ce qui reste tout à
fait théorique puisqu'il faudrait des
machines pour transformer cet oxygène en
ergols c'est ce qui va être testé en
fait avec persévérance mais si ça marche
il faudra encore envoyer les machines tu
fasses ça à grande échelle pour pouvoir
remplir une fusée bolt pour le retour la
question du décollage se pose aussi
quand 2.1 pas de départ du fise est de 4
caméras ça il y aura pas sur mars
donc on se demande comment fera une
suffisent ils pour décoller comme ça de
toute façon on it
on imagine que le jour on envoie 4 mars
youn haute vers mars
on aura envoyé avant des vaisseaux
cargos qui auront déposé un certain
nombre de deux tonnes de matériel qui
lorsqu'on nécessaire pour pouvoir
ensuite s'installer sur mars
quel que soit le temps qu'ils vont y
passer on y reviendra mais mais d'abord
ces quatre personnes
comment les choisir at on vous le dit
est ce qu'on va prendre un homme une
femme un couple marié c'est déjà arrivé
dans la dent et un vol pour pour sur l'
iss il y avait deux astronautes il
s'était marié en cachette avant vous
l'aviez dit pas ce qui est interdit par
la nasa
ils sont ils sont mariés en cachette ils
sont divorcés peuvent plus de remplacer
c'est trop tard
absolument c'est vrai que la question de
l'équipage c'est très délicat
on a cette image de l'astronaute très
vainqueur le héros sans peur ni reproche
et
bouffe un peu frondeur comme ça en fait
vraisemblablement si on veut que la
mission réussisse il faut il faut un peu
l' inverse
il faudra des gens qui soient très très
prêt à faire des compromis
les uns avec les autres il faudra des
gens avec une psychologie très souple ça
calme voilà la cohabitation et le stress
ou galy vont être valley mettre à rude
épreuve alors il faut bien imaginer ce
que c'est que d'être six ou sept mois
ensemble dans un habitacle extrêmement
petit 1 minute minuscule c'est pas c'est
pas quoi c'est pas la conquête des
océans par christophe colomb 1 c on est
dans un tout petit habitat il ya déjà eu
une expérience qui s'appelle le mars500
qui a été effectuée vous avez d'ailleurs
montré dans quelles conditions on voit
les images là je me trompe c'est ici
voilà dans quelles conditions en bas à
droite s'est réalisé le l'expérience par
500 qui consistait à rester cinq cents
jours comme ça isoler un plusieurs
personnes et vous dites vous ça s'est
fait dans des conditions quand même
assez confortable sachant que la navette
spatiale ça ressemble plutôt à ça et une
le vaisseau qui nous emmènera sur mars a
priori ressemblera plutôt à ça casse ah
oui sans compter la question d'une pour
lui qu'il ait continué sur le pss autant
que sur le véhicule qui partiraient la
liste des odeurs et l'apesanteur qu'on
ne peut pas évidemment simulé sur terre
alors c'est vrai que la promiscuité
ça va être le premier problème mais il
sait pas le seul la promiscuité de
quatre personnes pendant sept mois
c'est déjà un problème important la
sexualité en étant aussi que vous
abordez parce que sept mois quand même
selon trois axes en sachant plus quand
on est indépendant chanteur dès qu'on
s'approche on se repousse en fait
n'oublions la sexualité pour les six ou
sept mois l'hygiène ça on peut pas
l'oublier l'hygiène effectivement les
astronautes sont sont habitués à vivre
avec un minimum d'eau vous avez parlé de
11 litres c'est vraiment rien du tout si
on réfléchit alors le jeu connaît pas
les chiffres exacts pour pour la france
ou la suisse mais le l'américain moyen
il utilise largement 30 fois ça donc
donc 11 litres c'est vraiment avec un
minimum d'hygiène il n'y a évidemment
pas de bulle andrien pas moyen de laver
les vêtements dont qu'ils ont un peu des
vêtements de rechange pour pas rester
six mois dans les mêmes mais dix ans il
n'y a pas moyen de laver comme il faut
donc les odeurs c'est assez connu que la
station spatiale elle sent le vieux
gymnase mal aérée
on se lave avec des lingettes il faut se
dire quand on est un astronaute ne prend
pas de douche il prend pas de bain il se
lave avec les lingettes voilà et ils
sont mais dans l'espace en apesanteur on
transpire plus que sur telle est sans
compter que dans la station spatiale le
ballet les ravitailler une fois par mois
donc en gros ils peuvent avoir des
vêtements neufs une fois par mois ne
serait ce que des t-shirts ou des choses
comme ça pendant six mois fin pendant
trois ans
quand on part sur mars mais non c'est
l'événement le départ évidemment le
moins possible pour pas alourdir
c'est tout à fait différent au niveau
des gènes de ce qui se passe sur le sur
les ss et alors la première question que
se posent les enfants en général quand
on leur présente des astronautes
il leur demande toujours comment on fait
caca pipi dans l'espace c'est toujours
ça et donc j'imagine que le problème
sera le même peut-être même décuplé en
partant sur mars
alors évidemment pas les astronautes
sont bien habitués maintenant à utiliser
les toilettes qu'ils ont à disposition
donc c'est un système qui fait de la
succession en fait et donc il faut bien
le disposer ensuite ça aspire les choses
évidemment le l'importance est vraiment
immense puisque on recycle urine pour
faire de l'eau pour la pour la vie de
tous les jours des astronautes donc il
s'agit pas de perdre quoi que ce soit en
cours de route
le solide à éliminer un mais
effectivement les oui ça demande un peu
d'entraînement visiblement il ya souvent
des accidents vraisemblablement d'après
les récits des astronautes
parfois c'est un peu de temps pour
nettoyer après le passage au petit coin
quand vous dites qu'on recycle urines
donc on l'arbois après ce qu on reboise
sa propre ruine et or en bois l'uriné de
tout le monde alors s'est recyclé en
vrac donc tous les en fait la paire spi
ration aussi la transpiration ce qu'on
exhale en respirant n'exhale beaucoup
d'humidité tout ça est récupéré et avec
l'uriné recyclée alors ils ont essayé de
recréer en fait le cycle de l'eau le
même cycle de l'eau sur terre avec
évaporation condensation précipitations
accumulation et donc c'est grâce à ça
qu'ils ont réussi à faire en sorte que
les astronautes supporte un peu mieux
l'idée de boire l'uriné d'un peu tout le
monde c'est pas c'est plus de
l'imminente est quelque part nous
emboîtent buring de dinosaures tous les
jours à ce niveau mais enfin il faudrait
convaincre quand même ceux qui sont
prêts à dépenser 200 mille dollars pour
aller sur la sueur sur le starship de de
del bosque de savoir qu'ils boiront le
pipi de leurs voisins quoi exactement
ils ont c'est là où ça se complique pour
monsieur masquer cette bombe à 4
personnes hyper entraînés pendant des
années qui vont qui savent ce qu'ils
nient ce qui les attend
qui n'ont pas payé dessous de touristes
donc c'est plutôt de luxe qui peut-être
ne voudront pas boire ce genre de
liquide alors ravi avait parlé du bruit
le bruit très important pendant six sept
mois c'est un bruit infernal infernal
péter pas mais disons c'est l'équivalent
d'une route passante en permanence un
jour et nuit sans arrêt on fait et on
sait à quel point alors le le cerveau
s'habitue aux bruits ont fini par plus
vraiment l'entendre mais le corps subit
un stress continu dans un bruit continu
c'est quelque chose qui a reconnu dans
les villes en fait on sait que le bruit
des villes est néfaste pour la santé
et donc c'est une chose de plus qui
vient mettre en péril la santé des
astronautes et ce n'est pas que pendant
les six ou sept mois de voyage parce que
les maisons les habitats sur mars aussi
pressurisée donc il y aura aussi tout un
système de ventilation et de
pressurisation qui forcément fait de
bruit
peut-être même les astronautes partant
pour pour la lune donc tout ça mais un
voyage sur la lune c'était quoi une
semaine dix jours je me souviens plus je
crois que plus on a fait dix jours une
dizaine de jours bon là on parle de 7 6
7 mois c'est quand même très très
différents donc les demis et puis
évidemment la santé
la santé ça paraît primordial il s'agit
pas d'avoir une rage de dents pendant
notre voyage ni d'avoir l'appendicite
comment on résout le problème de la
santé alors je pense je suppose que
l'appendice les mascottes des futurs
marsionautes auront elles se seront fait
enlever l'appendicite et les dents de
sagesse j'imagine ce serait la moindre
des précautions
les astronautes ils sont formés à faire
des actes médicaux simples dons qui
peuvent intervenir vraiment en cas
d'urgence mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
savoir sur les ss ils peuvent être de
retour en 3h sur terre s'il ya vraiment
un
quelque chose de grave en trois heures
ils sont de retour tandis que sur mars
ce sera pas le cas donc effectivement il
va falloir mettre en place des jeux
c'est pas des protocoles avec un médecin
en ligne qui dit quoi faire
mais pour les petites bourses et aux
franchement oui
et puis alors ya la psychologie et alors
là on entre dans un territoire
totalement inconnu même si on a fait
l'expérience mars-500 partir sept mois
dans un vaisseau spatial bruyant avec
trois personnes trois autres personnes
sans pouvoir sortir ne plus voir la
terre vous le dites vous dites c'est
voit la terre s'éloigner puis la voir
disparaître parce qu'on la verra
disparaître
on la verra plus c'est quelque chose
qu'aucun homme n'a jamais connu non et
pour l'instant on n'a pas de pas le
moindre possibilité d'expérimenter ça
donc c'est vraiment là c'est de
l'inconnu total 1 fr et c'est surtout la
pression en fait parce que le shaq
chaque astronaute aura son rôle à jouer
dans la mission et la moindre erreur la
moindre faille en fait dans ce que les
gens doivent faire peut mettre en péril
tout le monde est en fait on sait que
déjà simplement sur l' iss les
astronautes qui doivent faire des
réparations qui doivent faire des
expériences
ils ont extrêmement peur de rater ils
veulent toujours ne pas être celui qui
aura fait l'erreur désagréable et ça
leur met une énorme pression est là on
peut imaginer que cette pression elle va
être centuplé en fait sur lui et se sont
mis à 400 km comme disait sylvia en cas
de problème revenir assez vite
et puis surtout ça n'a rien à voir avec
un appareil qui doit être entretenu par
quatre personnes pendant sept mois c'est
quoi les on sait il ya des gens qui se
retrouver à 2 je crois qu'il ya eu des
cow boys notion soviétique qui se
retrouvait à deux pendant très très
longtemps et on sait que ça s'est mal
passé il pouvait plus supporter oui il
ya eu un cadre effectivement assez vite
ils ont commencé à se détester et où ils
se sont plus adresser la parole pendant
toute là le reste de la mission et on
sait que ça a mis en péril en fait les
les actions qu'ils devaient faire en
fait tout ce qu'il devait accomplir
ils ont fini par même être très très
agressif envers le contrôle sur terre
donc ça peut on sait pas jusqu'où peut
mener la psychologie humaine et ça va à
notre avis c'est un c'est un gros
facteur limitant le facteur humain est
le plus compliqué à gérer
technologiquement on peut imaginer mais
le facteur humain est un prédictible et
et on sait ce qu'ils sont resté le plus
longtemps dans l'espace ils ont ramené
quelle sorte de témoignage quelles
impressions sur leur psychologie
qu'est ce que ça a eu comme effet
alors il trouve que c'est très longue
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours ce le le
début de la deuxième moitié qui est très
pénible
on sait qu'on tient on est parti pour du
long terme donc on tient bon et puis une
fois qu'on a passé la moitié on voit le
compte à rebours commence à diminuer et
en fait curieusement c'est là que ça
devient beaucoup plus difficile
on rencontre le même problème sur les
sur les stations antarctiques par
exemple le midwinter syndrom par exemple
ou au moment où on a passé le milieu de
l'hiver le milieu de la mission commence
à vraiment souffrir psychologiquement et
donc alors bien sûr c'est connu il ya
déjà des stratégies de soutien
psychologique qui peuvent être mises en
place on balise un petit peu tout ça
l'expérience mars-500 typiquement elle a
aussi servi à ce genre de choses à
essayer de voir quelle stratégie quand
ça commence à être tendues entre les
gens comment faire pour vour désamorcer
les conflits
mais même s mars500 il pouvait sortir à
tout moment à tout moment il pouvait
appuyer sur le bouton rouge d'ouvrir la
porte sans aller avant de se mettre à
s'entretuer pas du tout extrapolable au
voyage sur mars
on fait une pause et on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
nous ne vivrons pas sur mars ni ailleurs
c'est le titre du livre de sylvie ax
trop mais javier non bella qui vient de
lui paraître chez favre on a bien
compris la ce que c'était que de partir
pendant 6 ou 7 mois à 4 dans une petite
boîte en fer-blanc omis mais on n'a pas
encore étudié est ce que c'est être
d'aller dans l'espace parce que là tous
les problèmes que vous venez de décrire
srl et même si on nous enfermer dans une
boîte pendant six mois et qu'on la
laisse est sur terre mais là on part
dans l'espace on va sur mars et les
premiers risques que l'on rencontre
d'après ce que vous dites dans votre
livre
ce sont les radiations oui effectivement
le soleil nous envoie des toutes sortes
de rayon et toutes sortes de rayonnement
électromagnétique déjà ce qu'on appelle
la lumière et qui est plus que juste que
la lumière de nos yeux peuvent voir qui
correspond aussi aux rayons x aux rayons
gamma par exemple donc on est bombardé
en permanence de ce rayonnement du
soleil
et en plus comme on peut le voir sur
cette image une voie d éjection de
matière qu'on appelle le vent solaire et
donc là c'est des particules chargées
qui nous arrive dessus à une très grande
vitesse avec une grande énergie et ces
deux types de rayonnements sont vraiment
très dangereux pour la santé humaine
la terre elle al'avantage d'être dans
une double bulle
la première bulle c'est son atmosphère
qui représente à peu près 30 mètres de
béton pour par rapport à la protection
contre les radiations du soleil et non
seulement dans la cette protection là au
niveau du sol la station spatiale
internationale elle est plus haut et
l'air 400 km dans l'espace en fait au
dessus de la terre donc elle elle est la
moins cette protection mais quand même
encore une certaine couche d'atmosphère
au dessus d'elle mais on a aussi
l'avantagé que la terre génère un champ
magnétique très fort qui nous met dans
une immense bulle magnétique qui dévie
une bonne partie des radiations
une partie arrive quand même sur terre
c'est ce qui fait les magnifiques
aurores boréales qu'on peut admirer dans
le dans les régions polaires
mais le gros de la radiation est dévié
et ne nous atteint pas et donc on est
protégés sur la station spatiale les
astronautes sont protégés à partir du
moment
on va quitter cette bulle de protection
on va être complètement à nu entre
guillemets dans l'espace face à ces
radiations solaires
mais aussi des radiations cosmiques en
fait on a des rayons cosmiques qui nous
arrive de noyaux de galaxies lointaines
qui arrivent avec des énergies
époustouflante et qui met vraiment à
risque la santé humaine
donc ça veut dire que soit en blindes le
vaisseau et puis en plus on fait de
toutes petites ouvertures faut pas
s'attendre à des deux à d'immenses
fenêtres panoramiques sur l'espace ce
sera des tout petits boulots alors soit
des tout petits boulots soit même pas de
hublot du tout ça dépend un petit peu
les plans on peut pas faire des grandes
baies vitrées avec un une vitre qui soit
qui soit opaque oreille aux radiations
en fait on peut on peut faire des petits
hublots transparent mais par l'ap un
énorme
et effectivement alors blindé le
vaisseau c'est la première idée qu'on
aurait mais ce n'est pas forcément une
bonne idée parce que les rayons
cosmiques quand il tape un blindage ils
se cassent ils génèrent des cascades de
particules secondaires qui sont à peu
près tout aussi néfaste que le rayon
d'origine et donc en fait au lieu
d'avoir un rayon très très énergétique
on en reçoit tout une toute une série
qui sont à peine moins énergétiques donc
c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
l'un des blindages les mieux les plus
adaptés ces lots en fait tout ce qui est
toute substance qui est riche en
hydrogène est intéressante parce qu'elle
fait moins de particules secondaires
mais on ne peut pas tapie c'est tout un
vaisseau avec avec une paroi d'eau assez
épaisse donc l'idée c'est de faire un
blindage relatif d'une substance riche
en hydrogène et puis que les astronautes
râler martiaux notre porte des espèces
de gilets de protection qu'il est qui
protège les organes les plus sensibles
en espérant qu' aucun rayonnement
vraiment rayons cosmiques vraiment très
énergétiques ne les atteignent parce que
cela rien ne les arrête
bon ça déjà première grosse grosse
difficulté deuxième difficulté les
micrométéorites alors on voit ça dans
tous les films
en général on est
à bord du vaisseau et puis on voit plein
de météorites qui nous arrive de sueur
ou les évite
c'est comme ça que ça devrait se passer
ça ne va pas faire du slalom
non effectivement alors ça c'est un
autre danger c'est que c'est
qu'effectivement même une toute petite
particule avec les vitesses qui sont en
jeu elle peut pénétrer et faire des
dégâts la probabilité que ça fasse un
des gars vraiment important et les
faibles donc donc on peut espérer que ça
ne se passera pas mais ce n'est pas
exclu
effectivement c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit sur l' iss il ya régulièrement des
micro météorites qui font des dégâts des
débris spatiaux qui font des dégâts
oui c'est un problème humain tensions
entre mars et la terre il n'y a pas de
grosse météorite comme dans les films
que vous évoquez sont toutes petites
choses qui traînent dans le système
solaire
mais c'est passé gros c'est gros objets
bon c'est déjà ça passe quand il faudra
emporté des pièces de rechange
sachant que vous le dit dans dans le
livre sur l' iss on passe son temps à
réparer
on a constamment des vaisseaux qui
arrivent avec des pièces de rechange
là c'est très différent on part pour
mars on l'a dit on l'a compris il n'est
pas question de se faire ravitailler
donc on part avec les pièces de rechange
il a raison pour ce qui est du voyage
voilà il y aura pas de ravitaillement
passé mais il faut espérer que le voyage
habité a été précédée comme on disait
avant différents vols cargo qui aurait
par exemple déposé sur mas de quoi
réparer des petits problèmes ayant eu
lieu par une valve mais pendant le vol
il faut vraiment être sûr que tout
fonctionnait au moins d'avoir des pièces
de rechange moins à double entrée
problème parce que là franchement
langage problème mais c'est fini il faut
des systèmes redondants aussi il faut il
faut avoir plusieurs fois le même le
même appareil qui fonctionne d'autant
plus qu effectivement les appareils vont
fonctionner en permanence
alors on a une certaine habitude
maintenant avec liesse
il ya une certaine expérience de ce qui
est fait mais effectivement la
différence c'est qu'ils essaient sont
peu l'arabe italie facilement
il faudra vraiment prévoir beaucoup de
choses alors imaginons qu'on ait réussi
on est tous les quatre
on arrive sur mars au bout de six sept
mois de voyage on est très fatigué il
faut amar cyr
est-ce que c'est particulièrement
difficile des martyrs est ce que c'est
plus difficile
damart sire que d'atterrir ou d'alunir
alors en fait donc sur terre on a une
forte gravité mais on a aussi une forte
atmosphère qui peut freiner le vaisseau
sur la lune on a pas d'atmosphère et on
a une très faible gravité et sur mars
on a une gravité un peu plus forte que
la lune est pratiquement pas
d'atmosphère mais quand même un petit
peu
donc en fait on a un peu les les
désagréments les uns des autres
la peau ce faire va faire en traîne un
freinage mais relativement faible on
peut pas vraiment utiliser parachute il
faudrait un parachute absolument
gigantesque pour freiner une un des
sceaux comme ça donc la seule façon de
freiner c'est d'avoir des rétrofusées en
fait pour faire le freinage contre le
sol en fait en inversant la pousser au
moment où on atténue oui il faut bien se
rappeler que quand on envoie
persévérance c'est moins d'une tonne
là on avait quand même avec un vaisseau
de plusieurs tonnes
puisqu'avec toujours toutes les raisons
qu'on a dit voilà 20 à 30 tonnes c'est
énorme
danseur pas content et de toute façon
chaque fois qu'une sonde des états unis
arrive là bas il ya toujours ce moment
les sept minutes de terreur dont ils
parlent
à chaque acte chaque à marcy sage même
d'une sonde d'une tonne c'est un moment
de suspense insoutenable
alors imaginez pour fuser de 24 ans qui
plus est habitée et nono martiaux note
après six ou sept mois en apesanteur ils
sont dans quel état je me souviens de
thomas pesquet revenant de revenants de
liesse ses 10 ans qui arrivait même pas
de tir son téléphone
voilà c'est ce que nous disons plus
exactement le problème c'est que en
apesanteur les muscles fonde déjà d'une
part alors ça on peut faire des
exercices pour garder la musculation
c'est ce qu'ils font a d'ailleurs dans
l'eee et c'est ce qu'ils font à peu près
deux heures deux heures et demie de
sport chaque jour pour garder de la
musculature le plus possible
le problème l'autre problème c'est que
les os deviennent poreux on a une
déclassification des eaux comme comme
les femmes post ménopause qui perdent de
la masse osseuse mais ça se passe
beaucoup beaucoup plus rapidement en
apesanteur et donc on a des gens qui
s'ils font un peu un faux pas un grand
saut pour l'humanité risque la fracture
du fémur à l'atterrissage à bille le
coeur et le coeur devient très paresseux
à la présente hors puisque justement on
a plus de besoin de faire de trop gros
effort musculaire malgré les deux heures
et demie de travail donc le coeur n'y
est plus habitué à retrouver un exercice
normal ne manquent elles retrouveront
qui retrouveront la gravité martienne
même si les uns pierre que celle de la
terre il faut être très très fatiguée à
la ne pourront pas se lever comme ça
tranquillement et on voit bien justement
quand thomas pesquet ou d'autres
reviennent de liesse après six mois
seulement qu'ils sont sains et ait pas
se mettre debout dans l'oreille interne
mais l'oreille interne est complètement
au pire elle en est entré après ils ont
interdiction de conduire une voiture
pendant six mois après un retour donc ça
veut dire que ou mettre longtemps à se
remettre de la pesanteur et sur mars
il n'y a pas de comité d'accueil voilà
oui les différence c'est que là tout ce
que vous décrivez c'est quand on revient
sur terre
donc tout est fini on peut se reposer
nous là ils se retrouveront dans le même
état mais au début une fois arrivé sur
mars il sera au tout début
et alors est ce que la solution ce
serait pas de parvenir à maintenir la
gravité terrestre dans le vaisseau
spatial s'est généralement ce qu'on voit
dans les films depuis 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace le film de kubrick
on voit bien que dans le vaisseau
spatial les gens marchent normalement ou
à peu près je dirais que c'est à peu
près la seule solution raisonnable
en revanche au niveau technologique et
financier je sais pas si c'est très
raisonnable
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué il ya des
tests ils sont faits en fait pour les
mettre dans une espèce de centrifugeuses
et oui le fait de passer quelques heures
par semaine même simplement dans cette
centrifugeuse permettrait de garder plus
de masse osseuse et de moins risquées
ces problèmes les problèmes liés à
l'oreille interne je suis pas sûr que ça
améliore beaucoup donc qui vont de toute
façon avoir de la peine à se mettre
debout la chance qu'ils ont c'est que
mars est quand même une gravité plus
faibles donc même s'ils ont des eaux un
peu moins solide même s'ils sont un
petit peu perturbé il ya des chances
quand même que les 600 sorte peut-être
mais effectivement la difficulté c'est
qu'ils auront personnes pour les
accueillir ils devront vraiment se
débrouiller et comment comme j'ai dit on
fait atterrir la fusée avec des
rétrofusées donc ça va générer beaucoup
de chaleur et de vaporiser le régolithe
la poussière martienne donc il est exclu
de faire atterrir la fusée tout près des
habitations qui aurait été sans doute
déjà construits par en tout cas du
matériel des habitations
ils sont obligés de faire atterrir la
fusée dans un loin dans un coin isolé
faire en tout cas un demi kilomètre ou 1
km de trajet avant de récupérer leur
matériel et dans l'état où il se rend ce
sera vraiment très très longue c'est 500
être parce que évidemment une fois
qu'ils sont là où il va falloir
construire quelque chose pour pouvoir
rester là un certain temps une base en
tout cas commencé à imaginer la base
martienne dont la base des terriens sur
mars celle dont nous rêvons tous
celle là alors qu'est ce qu'on imagine
on parle de se réfugier dans des tunnels
c'est quoi ces tunnels sur mars où on
pourrait se réfugier
parce que il ya de la poussière vous
l'avais dit il ya des tempêtes sur mars
c'est pas du tout une sais pas c'est pas
les bermudes surtout y le même problème
qui se pose on parlait s'élevait en
france elles les radiations du cosmique
et les radiations du soleil ça ça
continue donc il faut se protéger et
pour ça il a été pensé dans les réfugiés
dans des tunnels de lave qui sont ok
tunnel de l'air s'est simplement quand
la lave coule l'extérieur se refroidit
beaucoup plus vite et la lave coule à
l'intérieur et parfois ça fait du tunnel
on envoie à la réunion l'envoi la hawaii
il ya ces tunnels comme ça qui sont
relativement petit sur terre mais sur
mars et sur la lune il semblerait qu'ils
peuvent être plus grand du fait de la
faible gravité et donc l'idée ce serait
effectivement de pourquoi pas aller
mettre les habitations là dedans ce qui
produirait une espèce de protection
naturelle 1 contre la radiation
parce que l'autre option c'est de devoir
construire la protection des habitations
avec le régolithe martiens et ça on est
absolument incapable de dire maintenant
si c'est possible
persévérance va préparer des petits
échantillons qu'une autre mission doit
venir récupérer et qu'une encore
troisième mission doit ramener sur terre
et seulement quand on aura ces
échantillons là on pourra savoir de brel
réellement comment de quoi il fait leur
ego dit martien de quoi à quoi il
ressemble quelles sont ses capacités
physiques en fait est ce qu'on peut le
contacter pour faire des briques ou bien
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui reste
qui s'effrite qui est absolument pas
utilisable si c'est pas utilisable
savent a posé d'immenses problèmes si
c'est utilisable on peut imaginer qu
effectivement on arrive à faire
fabriquer des espèces de murs de
protection grâce aux ego dit lui en
envoyant une entreprise de btp à skis
mais pose d'autres problèmes encore quoi
alors les combinaisons
il nous faudra des combinaisons là haut
ne serait ce que voit dans quoi en quoi
pour pour affronter l'atmosphère
martienne donc les combinaisons elles
doivent assurer la stabilité en
température puisqu'il ya des grands
écarts de température entre le jour et
la nuit
on arrive à peu près 20 degrés la
journée en 0 yvan régler la journée et
puis on est à moins à moins cent pendant
la nuit
donc de toute façon il faut il faut
assurer la stabilité en température et
surtout il faut maintenir la pression
pour le pour que le corps des
astronautes ne se défasse pas dans
l'espace comme à la fin de total recall
et donc il faut il faut des combinaison
pressurisée comme on peut pas les
pressurisée trop parce que sinon il
serait juste complètement rigide dedans
à rien pouvoir faire
on est obligé d'y mettre une atmosphère
pratiquement pur d'oxygène et donc on a
le problème de la maladie des caissons
on est obligé de descendre en pression
par paliers pour que le la zot du sens
élimine avant avant qu'on soit
dépressurisé vraiment et qu'on soit sans
oxygène donc ça demande une préparation
ça veut dire que l'on peut pas juste
dire bon j'étais assez vu j'en ai marre
je sors et puis s'en aller
non il faut passer la nuit sous oxygène
avant de pouvoir sortir ces choses qui
s'improvisent et voilà il ya tous les
problèmes de risque de maladies des
caissons que connaissent bien les
plongeurs ont fait et puis à la bid ou
la poussière martienne donc il va
falloir les nettoyer ces combinaisons en
permanence nettoyer le vaisseau des
toyer tout il faut garder la poussière
or des invitations martienne à tout prix
donc il ya des idées de faire un espèce
de sas qui permettrait d'entrer dans la
combinaison centre la combinaison entre
dans les habitations
parce que le problème dure et gullit
martien il semble qu'il est qu'il soit
bourré de passes chlorate qui est un
polluant tout à fait
néfaste pour la santé humaine et en plus
ce regoli tu sais ce qui cause la
silicose chez les mineurs c'est le même
c'est le même type de substance que ce
qui fait la silicose les mineurs donc on
veut absolument pas de cette poussière
dans les habitations il faut la
maintenir à l'extérieur coûte que coûte
et ce en quoi le système de sortie qu'on
a maintenant c'est des heures et des
heures de préparation pour quelques
heures à l'extérieur il ya une deuxième
version qui est à l'étude
c'est de passer une heure en préparation
pour une heure à l'extérieur revenir une
heure de compression de pressurisation
ressortir une heure donc de toutes
façons c'est extrêmement lourd comme
processus s'est pas laissé les gars je
ne sors pas pour ne pas apporter au sort
comme comme on a pu le faire pendant le
confinement ici là bas c'est un vrai
confinement donc filmé en plus et les
tempêtes parce qu'elles sont fameuses
les tempêtes martienne
elle ressemble pas du tout à ce
qu'assure seul sur malsain parce que la
densité de l'atmosphère est très très
faible
donc c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui
va vous plaquer basse terre tellement
c'est violent en revanche ça va faire
sans fil très dur et gullit vraiment
dans les moindres interstices et ça peut
couvrir ça peut ça peut bloquer la
lumière du soleil pendant longtemps
c'est pour ça que tout les toutes les
missions maintenant toutes les sondes
maintenant pacte avec un petit moteur
nucléaire
un petit générateur nucléaire parce que
les panneaux solaires malheureusement
sont un risque d'être recouverts de
réguler it
alors là une tempête peut chasser le
régolithe d'un panneau recouvert comme
elle peut leur couvrir de poussière mais
disons c'est un c'est un apport en
énergie qui est un petit peu douteux à
cause de sa fac et donc pas très fiable
à cause de ça bon c'est pas tous les
jours non plus une grosse tempête
merci m qui recouvre toute la planète
c'est cette chaque trois ans martien en
gros donc c'est pas tous les jours par
contre il ya des petits des mini petit
cyclone qui sont qui organise
régulièrement et puis surtout d'une
rigole it en suspension tout le temps
mais là ça fait du fait de la fête de
gravité de mars le rigolo ne se pose
jamais vraiment en fait
là ça fait sept mois qu'on a voyagé
qu'on a mangé de la nourriture
lyophilisée
on n'en peut plus on ne rêve que d'une
chose c'est de cultiver des aliments
on se souvient tous du formidable film
de ridley scott seul sur mars avec matt
damon ou où on l'a oublié sur mars et où
il se met à cultiver avec succès est ce
que c'est possible
alors si c'était possible il y aurait il
y aurait des immenses champs de patates
dans le sahara on se rend bien compte
que c'est pas possible de juste aller
faire nos besoins dans le sable du
sahara et de du coup pouvoir en obtenir
de l'ue de l'humus capable de supporter
de l'agriculture ce serait ça serait
déjà fait dans le désert en fait c'est
beaucoup plus complexe pour faire
pousser les choses soit il faut il faut
le faire avec l'hydroponie ou de ce
qu'ils font même de l'aéroport ni mais
cette cdc des systèmes complexes est
vraiment juste prendre un peu de
poussière de sable martiens et et faire
caca dans ce cache pas et si ça marche
pas on a des carences terrible non même
au bout de sept huit mois si on a mangé
que de l'alu nourriture lyophilisée on
n'a pas des problèmes alors c'est un peu
le risque effectivement il
d'autant plus que pour lutter contre les
problèmes de radiation c'est très
important d'avoir des vitamines et des
antioxydants et donc l'idée c'est
d'essayer quand même de cultiver ce
conte l'aéropot ni ou en hydroponie
justement avec des systèmes d petit
caisson emmené depuis la terre et qui
permettent de cultiver un peu alors pour
le moment on a réussi à faire pousser
des batavias et je sais plus quel
montrait aliments de la moutarde je
crois qu'ils ont monté des graines de
moutarde donc on a des espoirs d'arriver
à faire un tout petit peu
variez un tout petit peu l'ordinaire des
astronautes mai mais il faut bien se
rendre compte que on ne peut pas
cultiver n'importe quoi danse avec ces
techniques on peut pas faire des
céréales on peut pas faire des
légumineuses on peut pas faire des
patates justement ça marche pas donc oui
c'est quelque chose de compliqué le
ferons dès l'instant où on va dès
l'instant on va marcher sur mars
est ce que l'on peut lui le sol martien
est ce qu'on a c'est vers snow germe nos
barques magnum bactéries ça c'est une
des choses qui nous qui nous concerne
nous pour lesquelles on est on est
sensible effectivement toutes les sondes
qu' on en voit dans le système solaire
d'une manière générale et qu'on envoie
sur mars on les stérilisent au plus haut
point pour éviter toute contamination au
cas où on voudrait un jour chercher la
ville sur ces corps pour ne pas risquer
d'y avoir laissé des bactéries humaines
l'as des as si on envoie des astronautes
ont pas pouvoir stériliser les choses et
les hommes donc donc oui il ya le risque
de contaminer mars
est ce que ça peut nous empêcher de
chercher un passé de vie sur mars
la question est complexe c'est vrai que
si on trouve des fossiles de bactérie e
on pourra être sûr que c'est bien du
martien mais si on trouve d un peu d il
y aura toujours le doute en fait de se
dire est ce que est ce que vraiment si
on si on retrouve des bactéries quelque
part est ce que c'est des bactéries
humaines
tu aurais peut-être muté mais qui serait
partie de la terre ou pas c'est le doute
est il ya des astrophysiciens qui essaye
de faire un moratoire pour demander que
qu'on en voit rien d'humain peu qu'on
n'envoie personne parce que c'est pas
possible de contrôler comme il faut et
qu'il faudrait d'abord répondre à la
question y at il eu la vie sur mars
avant d'envoyer des bonhommes même si on
entend souvent le linverse c'est à dire
que c'est en envoyant des bonhommes
qu'on pourra vraiment chercher s'il ya
de la vie sur mance donc c'est un peu un
casse tête comment bien faire les choses
et c'est vrai que à notre avis on l'a
envoyé des gens sur mars est contaminée
mars est donc risqué de ne pas pouvoir
répondre à cette question est
fondamentale
alors on a vu à quel point ce serait
difficile d'envoyer des gens sur mars
normal c'est possible vous on a listé
toutes les difficultés mais enfin c'est
possible mais l'idée qu'il ya derrière
tout ça c'est l'idée que ces colonisés
mars
c'est l'idée d'elon musk c'est l'idée de
la plupart des films que l'on voit sur
mars et vous vous dites ça c'est pas
possible du tout nous ne vivrons pas
mieux sur mars
ni ailleurs vous êtes sûr de vous oui on
est assez sûr de tous l'avenir me
donnera peut-être tort mais on prend le
risque c'est à dire coeur vivre vivre
une vie qui soit digne de ce nom je
pense que ce n'est pas possible sur mars
envoyer des gens en masse sa demande d
infrastructures gigantesques on ne sait
même pas comment faire survivre quatre
bonhommes pendant trois ans pour le
moment celton nous promettent d'aider
ville d'un million d'habitants ok c'est
des gens qui balaye toutes les
difficultés en dix ans mais il ya cas il
suffit de et on évoquant des solutions
technologiques qu'on connaît encore pas
qu'on sait encore pas faire alors
peut-être qu'un jour on le saura ce
n'est pas exclu mais disons c'est
vraiment très très invraisemblable est
effectivement pour nous l'option de
coloniser mars déjà de toute façon on va
pas pouvoir rendre mars un lieu
habitable
on y fera que survivre que survivent
dans une espèce de bulle artificielle
mais c'est pas une alternative à une
planètes comme la terre c'est ça c'est
ça qu'on essaye de vraiment de
transmettre avec notre livre c'est que
la seule la nette habitable c'est la
terre et nos organismes humains ils ont
évolué sur la terre avec ces
considérations physiques ses
caractéristiques physiques et c'est ça
qui fait qu' on est qui nous qui nous
avons rendu tel qu'on est
et donc sortir de ce milieu là c'est
c'est de l'ordre de la survie uniquement
pas de la ville c'est de la survie en
avec avait dû effectivement des
ravitaillements et des peut-être des
solutions pour essayer de nous maintenir
comme on peut mais c'est de l'ordre de
la survie n'est pas de l'ordre de la vie
et malheureusement la science fiction
dont on a parlé plusieurs fois depuis
quelques décennies amis dont le dans le
public l'idée que vivre dans des
vaisseaux intérêt tactique extrêmement
facile et à la portée de tout le monde
on appuie sur un bouton et hop on passe
en vitesse de la lumière quand on est
dans le flou comme millenium de ses
solos les objets ne flotte pas alors
qu'il n'ait pas de graves y voilà la
science-fiction facilité des choses qui
sont en fait impossible dans l'esprit
collectif
néanmoins on pourrait y aller me dites
pas qu'on ne peut pas y aller c'est pas
ou si c'est possible d'y aller alors
pour l'instant on sait pas faire
la nasa le reconnaît elle elle
conditionne le voyage vers mars
au retour sur la lune déjà il faut déjà
simplement essayer de retourner sur la
lune et d'y vivre plus que quelques
heures
ce que faisaient les missions apollo est
donc une fois qu'on aura fait sa une
fois qu'on aura ramené des échantillons
de mars qu'on aura pu justement tester
les caractéristiques physiques du
rigolet essayé de tester des
technologies là bas peut-être qu'on peut
envisager un voyage vers mars mais même
la nasa elle ne dit pas oui on va aller
vers mars
elle le dit disons mais mais en disant
on va déjà essayer simplement de
retourner sur la lune et d'avoir une
base permanente sur la lune et déjà ça
c'est pas gagné
merci tous les deux nous ne vivrons pas
sur mars ni ailleurs c'est signé sylvia
extrême et javier non bella avec une
préface du prix nobel de physique michel
mayor c'est paru chez favre et c'est un
livre tout à fait passionnant
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]